welcome to this episode of click to
deploy a series where we show you how
easy it is to deploy solutions from the
google cloud marketplace in this episode
we'll be reviewing how to set up netapp
cloud volumes on tap via the cloud
marketplace
netapp cloud volumes on tap in google
cloud is a data management layer that
runs natively on google cloud
infrastructure enabling enhanced control
data protection mobility and agility for
business application data
let's start by searching for cloud
volumes on tap in the google cloud
marketplace for this demo we'll choose
the solution cloud manager for cloud
volumes on tap
the landing page will display
information about the solution
pricing documentation and support to use
cloud manager and cloud volumes on tap
google cloud users need to subscribe to
cloud volumes on tap via the google
cloud marketplace
let's click the subscribe button to
launch the solution
start first by choosing a billing
account and agreeing to the terms below
which are terms about subscription fee
billed monthly and cancelling the
service
after choosing the subscribe button you
will see a notification to register with
netapp inc before we visit netapp let's
make sure to create a google cloud
account with the necessary identity and
access management iam policy
this will make it possible to use cloud
manager with your google cloud
environment
from this netapp website download the
connector deployment policy for gcp and
the cloud manager policy for gcp
let's create a custom role for the
connector deployment and assign it to a
user
in the cloud shell upload the setup as
service version gcp yamo permission file
you previously downloaded
for the cloud shell use this command to
create a custom role for the file at the
organization or project level
we'll make this role at the project
level
the rule created using the permission
file will be titled netapp cloud central
to grant the new role created to the
relevant user you can run the gcloud add
iem policy binding command
next let's set up a service account that
will be associated with the connector vm
start by uploading policy for cloud
manager version
gcp.yml permission file to the cloud
shell
then go to iem and admin
navigate to service account
then create a new service account
for a service account name choose netapp
connector
for role choose netapp cloud central
now we have a google cloud user with the
permissions required to create a
connector from cod manager
as well as a service account for the
connector vm let's enable cloud api
needed for cloud volumes go to api and
service tab
we'll need to make sure the following
apis are enabled
cloud deployment manager v2 api
cloud logging api
cloud resource manager api
compute engine api
identity and access management iem api
now let's deploy netapp first go to the
marketplace
cloud volumes landing page and choose
manage on provider
create an account or walk into your
existing account
next we'll navigate to fabric view
and choose cod volumes on tap
go to cloud manager
let's add our first working environment
first we'll choose google cloud platform
next we'll choose cloud volumes on tap
now let's create a connector which
allows cloud manager to manage resources
and processes within your public cloud
environment we'll choose google cloud
platform we will need to provide
permissions to connect our google
account with cloud manager
we'll set our connector instance name
let's use test connector
we'll set the project it will be
connected to test ctd
we'll set service account netapp
connector
next we'll set the location details i'll
keep the defaults
then we'll set the connectivity to
public ip enable
and finally for the firewall policy
choose my ip
now that we filled out all this
additional information make sure to
review the details
as you can see the connector was
successfully created congratulations on
successfully deploying a netapp cloud
volumes on tap instance you now have a
platform to simplify the management of
your workloads on google cloud
if you enjoyed this video please
subscribe and hit the like button below
we encourage you to check out the google
cloud marketplace and deploy the
solution on your own thanks for watching
[Music]
you